foreign
Gainesville Florida what's up Chris
uh not too much Dr John it's an honor to
speak with you thank you for taking my
call it's an honor to talk to you
brother what's up man
uh so I'll I'll be brief uh give you a
little background and then I guess we
can uh go over the conversation leads uh
but uh so over time uh my relationship
with my mom has degraded to the point
that I no longer wish to have a
relationship with her how old are you um
I'm 40. 40 okay how old is she uh she is
70. okay cool thanks man
uh so I feel that as the years have gone
on that my family and I are are less and
less of a priority
um but what stops me is she's still my
mom
um I uh but even when when we travel to
go back home or even when I see her name
come up on a phone call I instantly gain
anxiety and it's to a point to it's not
crippling but it's to a point to where I
I feel I'm uncomfortable even afterwards
or even leading up to travel
um so I've read your book um own your
past change your future and
um this brick has been in my backpack
for years
um but given given the nature of who it
is
I I need some help learning how to set
it down and let it go cool man
um not really man I appreciate that call
uh you are not alone my brother in that
one so thanks for um Having the courage
to reach out
um what did your mom do
uh so she's not retired what did she do
to you
what does she do to you
um so I am I'm an active duty service
member so unfortunately my family is an
army rat family in tow uh so we've we've
moved all around the country and we
still continue to uh but for the longest
time wait a minute wait a minute what do
you mean unfortunately
well so uh it's a it's a path that I
chose and my family uh my family's been
along for the ride and they have been
extremely supportive through through the
whole uh through the whole ordeal
um did you tell your wife you were gonna
work at Home Depot and then suddenly you
came home and you're like surprise I
enlisted
uh so no a funny story with uh with how
I met my wife uh not even two months
after my deployment to Iraq and uh as
she was she was on board with a soldier
from right then and there so no it
wasn't a surprise so she chose you too
she did so she chose this life
she did and your kids are gonna get to
see all parts of the country and the
world and meet all kinds of new people
learn from different adults and children
their own age
oh they are that's incredible
no more ever seeing unfortunately
cool yes sir yes I grew up in the same
home in the same town on the same street
in the same place and I had a great
childhood
and it's also terrifying for me to be
away from my house
right which is a makes it tough to live
in a modern world so I liked being
stable I also wish man I'd gotten some
opportunities to go out and see some
stuff so it's going to be 6.5 another
your kids are lucky to have you cool
yes okay all right back to it sorry for
the interruption oh no no problem at all
okay so what what is why does your mom
make you anxious what does she do man
so it stemmed from I I I would say even
even back when when I was in college uh
so we uh so some background on that so
my um my mother and father divorced
after 40 years just a few years back
um but in reality even
um even myself and my siblings we
thought if it was going to happen it
should have happened 20 years ago uh so
we were not a close-knit family that
drifted apart I think we've kind of been
uh we've kind of just had this Dynamic
for years uh to the extent to where like
I I just I never enjoyed going home my
my sister graduated from college and she
had an apartment and her relationship
went South and she moved back home at 25
and is still there today so what made
you uncomfortable when you went back
people whining and complaining about
everything are they poking at you or
they saying man you're getting fat or
why you have a beard or you never even
come around anymore oh goody two like
what is it what was it about the things
that you showed up up to
so it was always for holidays but for
the longest time me and my family we
lived 45 minutes away
but my family only made it a priority to
come over on holidays but uh I guess
it's a social media to me has just been
like a a terrible enabler as well
because on social media my mom would
would then decide to post stuff that oh
I miss my grandkids or I miss my family
so much but she doesn't call for
birthdays
um she will post on Facebook or even
even as her own son I would get a text
on my birthday you know at 10 pm at
night because I think she may have seen
something on social media to remember
that oh it's it's my son's birthday yeah
so
before your parents got divorced you
mentioned about college take me back to
Middle School
what was Middle School like in your
house
um Middle School wasn't uh it wasn't too
bad
um
around that time um my brother was in
high school and I so with me being in
Middle School
um I guess so there was a significant
family event my my brother was in a
terrible car accident that uh that put
him in the hospital for quite some time
um so that shifted the family Dynamic a
little bit but
um my my dad has always kind of been
distant he's an outdoorsy person my mom
wasn't
um so like my dad was he was more of a
weekend dad because he would uh he would
stay he would probably he would stay out
on the farm in the cabin through the
week because that's what he enjoyed to
do but then we we got together on the
weekends
and after your brother's accident did
Mom
dial up the anxiety in the house
um a little bit and it took a while to
to figure that out
um so uh we uh my brother passed away
back in 2009 from an accidental overdose
and uh my mom couldn't handle it we all
struggled pretty hard uh but it was only
then when we learned um because uh my
mom almost died of a prescription pill
overdose that she had battled with uh
with prescription meds ever since my
brother was in an accident in the 90s so
just just for the sake of brevity
you've probably heard this but if you
haven't
um
I'll say it anyway
trauma can be affirmative it could be a
thing that somebody does to you
it can also be a thing that somebody
kept from you that they should have
given you
and connection with an adult is oxygen
for a child
and so nobody put their hands around
your throat but you were suffocated as a
kid
and living with an addict
is like trying to hug a ghost you see
them and every time you try to hold on
tight your hands go right through them
right they're present with you but
they're not there
and for a kid
especially with pills especially with
pills
kids go crazy
because they see that person in front of
them that they're supposed to love
and that person doesn't respond in a in
a way that makes sense to a little kid's
body and I say a little kid I'm talking
about through High School
and so it doesn't surprise me the least
bit and you and I could probably sit
down dude and grab a drink and just talk
all the way through it but man it
doesn't surprise me for a little bit
that that family system set your bodies
alarms off that we're not safe here
this isn't a smart place for us to be
right
right and
I want you to hold that tension with
this thing I'm about to tell you okay it
could be
that you got a mom with a lot of guilt
and a lot of Shame
who looks at the world this way my
little boy left me
he had to get out of here and I
understand it and so he went to the
military to get away from me
and then he married somebody who was all
in on the military now they move around
every year and I don't want to bother
them
so I'm just gonna I'll miss some like
bloody hell and I love them but I'm just
gonna post about it I'm not even gonna
Reach Out
I don't want to bother them I've done
enough damage for one lifetime
I'm giving her a ton of Grace
when I do that okay
here's why I'm telling you that
it doesn't matter
what matters is this
you don't like who you become in the
presence of certain people you don't
like how your body responds you don't
like the way that it makes you short
around your family you don't like the
way that your kids get dragged through
your attention as you're packing up to
go to a place you don't even want to be
taking them
right all that works together
so I want you to relax and drop your
shoulders and Trust Chris
I believe deeply that we need to respect
our parents even when they haven't been
good to us but that doesn't mean that
means I'm going to treat you with
dignity and kindness
sometimes the most dignified thing I can
do if you're an abusive parent is not
talk to you
okay
you're holding on to a fantasy
that you either need to get right smack
in the middle of or you need to let go
is that fair you're holding on to a
fantasy that your mom is suddenly gonna
loop back around and become this
incredible grandmother and it's going to
become a party again maybe even your
parents will get back together like you
know what I mean that whole line
and there's something heartbreaking like
dude what is it about my kids you ain't
calling their birthday
like what did they do right you know
what I mean
yeah
so either you get in a car and go drive
to her house and say I miss my mom and
we had a terrible childhood
and I want to rebuild this relationship
starting today and I'm going first
I moved all over the world and I miss
you and I hope you didn't take that
personal that it was something against
you something I wanted to do and I'm a
service oriented guy you raised me that
way I want to recreate this thing but
here's the my boundaries for it you can
do that
and if you do it golly Chris it's a risk
man because she could say no
she could blame you for everything
whatever or she might weep and say I'm
so glad my boy came home that could
happen the other one could be man give
yourself some Grace and some peace and
set it down
say man it would have been awesome to
have a grandma like this that was all in
on her kids that would come that drive
that 45 minute drive so much that we had
to tell her quit coming over because
you're here all the time
and that's not the grandma my kids got
and this is the reality that I find
myself in
which one of those sounds like a better
option
the second one
I feel like you need to let it go
I do
um yeah so and that's the that's the
background so like me and my wife are
like the perfect Dynamic
um that we're opposites and
I've I've battled with it for a while
um and and my wife's family are super
close-knit
um like they uh like her and her sister
talk every single day multiple times a
day like she talks to her mom all the
time and and I realize that so I I did
come to reality that I realized that
um I'm not I'm not asking for my mom to
be her mom I know but wait hold on
that's where I struggle but it'd be
awesome if she was right it would okay
it would
when you acknowledge that you
immediately will hit a water slide down
into
[Music]
and you've been there before as a
serviceman in that black hole of grief
like damn it my mom should show up and
see her grandkids and want be proud of
me
and she won't say those words that's
grief
I wanted this to be this way and here's
what it actually is
and if you'll sit there for a minute
and probably go one step further and
write that
11 or 12 year old Chris a letter
letting him know I'm sorry
this you shouldn't have been dragged
through this sorry brother got hurt I'm
sorry my dad he actually divorced mom 30
years ago they started fighting 20 years
ago and then they finalized it 10 years
ago
sorry that Mom was an addict and wasn't
there for you deserve better than that
you gotta you gotta connect with that
kid let him know
um it's time for him to go run and play
because he's 11.
he doesn't need to be holding a
household together at that age
because you're still trying to hold it
all together now dude
is that fair
it is it is it's very clear
I'm sorry man
jeez
how old are your kids
uh so one is 13 and the other one turned
seven in two months they're awesome
they're amazing they are the I I
couldn't have asked for better kids and
it makes no sense that somebody wouldn't
want to hang out with them does it
none whatsoever okay
they're not hanging out with y'all
because they're working through things
it's not because there's a problem with
you
okay
okay
I hate that
I hate that
I'm at some point they come back around
that's my guess
but that day is not today
um
we're coming up on a couple of months
out from the holiday season
this may be a great year to practice
and proactively let everybody know hey
this particular holiday season we're
going to be traveling somewhere else or
we're going to be staying at home this
year and so
um
we're going to send Grandma a card kids
we're going to write this and send it
and then I'm going to put that to rest
well
I could if I could interject then
another question so I think where the
guilt comes from is so obviously um so
they're back in the midwest
um with where I met my wife that's where
the guilt comes in about visiting is
that her in like so my in-laws my wife's
parents live six miles from my mom okay
and so when we go home
that's normally where I feel I get
guilted into going
um because that I feel that like her
family will travel to come see their
grandkids but it seems like we only
become a priority and we're expected to
visit only when we make that effort to
go all the way home so you got two
choices man you cannot go
and say sorry guys might be able to make
it this year
or you can go and
I guess you got three choices you can do
that to say sorry we're not able to make
it this year and by the way dude they
have cashed out their vote
they have chosen to not participate in
the functioning of his family
it's like people who don't vote and they
yell about the president you don't get
to do that if you don't play
right and so right
they don't get a vote they can yell real
loud it's annoying and it hurts but they
don't get a vote that's one number two
you can go just try to make the fantasy
come true and meet all of their needs
which you know is a moving it's a moving
Finish Line you can never get to the end
of that line because it always moves
because as soon as you've been there six
hours you actually had a good visit
someone's gonna say how come you're
never coming around anymore you too good
for us and then oh gosh we're right back
to where we started right
the third thing is you can go visit her
family and have a wonderful holiday and
tell your family I will be available for
lunch on this day
if y'all would like to have lunch I
would love to be there
and we'll be there from 12 to 3.
and those are that's just called
Boundaries
and if they say well we can't make it
because Timmy's got a fishing tournament
and Billy's going to be a that's great
what they are doing is they're choosing
not to be with you and that hurts
especially they're going to blame you
for it right
right but that's one of three options
and here's the deal
make peace with the choice man
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong
but I do know this I trust you
to do what's right for your family
so do what's right for them
do what's right for you
and be at peace man
you're not gonna be let me say it this
way you're not going to be able to think
yourself into the right action you're
gonna have to do something
and at the end of this holiday season if
you choose to not go you choose to go
all the way to the Midwest hang out with
her family and not go see your family
you'll know if that was right
you'll know
and then next year you have some more
data and you can make a different choice
or
you go you do know this you know that
traveling down there and doing it makes
you feel like a prostitute right
yes yeah so you got that piece of data
try something else is that fair
it's fair yes yeah cool Tada I should
have led with that uh try something else
man
um
let me say it this way
you're
you and your family are worth having a
good holiday season
and you can love your mom and respect
her and not let her participate in
bringing your holiday season down
that doesn't mean you love her less that
doesn't mean you're disrespecting her
that doesn't mean whatever just respect
doesn't mean you have to do whatever
somebody else says even to your family's
detriment
it doesn't
and you have to grieve the fact that you
wish your mother was something that she
has chosen to not be and that hurts and
I'm sorry and same with your dad and
same with your brothers
I will say this I'm grateful for you
I'm grateful for the sacrifice your
family
and I trust you
so you should trust you